[Music]
that was a quick pee I'll tell you
that's getting even Shake
should we should we start yeah let's
start with that what the hell hell yeah
we're rolling oh hey hey hello great
guest in studio beardas yeah check out
his new Netflix special Landing no
please do yeah yeah very good man thank
you man yeah very I mean a lot of a lot
of controversy yes you've been arrested
I was about to and then didn't oh okay
so I've been over the cops like you yeah
they do that's like that really works in
your favor it does yeah cops like comedy
or cops are like hey comedy Norman
whatever I tell they love it tell I bet
the guys who arrested Lenny Bruce were
like we like you right you just have to
I saw an Indian cop the other day like
real estate New York City and I I don't
know if that's a thing or it's not a
thing but it's going to make me happy to
see one yeah yeah
like not use average Indian height which
is my height as well so I'm like I don't
know who you're arresting but I
appreciate that you exist you know you
don't see a lot of Jewish cops no we're
not really represented if somebody
arrests you while complaining about
their life
you know we do the paperwork but uh yeah
never seen a cop with the yamaka no I
mean you wouldn't they wouldn't yeah ah
true true what about so for those that
don't know the controversy came from
this speech you gave at the Kennedy
Center oh yeah at the end of a show it
was the two Indians so here's what I can
say about it without uh beginning
another news cycle for myself oh [__] so
uh I made a YouTube video at the end of
my thing at the Kennedy Center I done a
show put it up and it was kind of in the
vein of many YouTube videos are done and
three days really good stuff lots of
views and then I think we all have the
angry news channel oh yeah right so we
have an angry News Channel they picked
it up that led to angry people angry
comments I was trending angry people
files and complaints against me we
didn't know what was going to happen and
I had to turn my phone off for like 45
days trending is terrifying trending is
terrible when you start comedy you're
like I wish I was trending and then when
you're trending you're like oh God this
is horrifying yeah Cosby was trending
exactly you don't always
yeah he's back just got back from
Pittsburgh and more boy are my victims
tired I don't know if I liked it we went
from me to Bill Cosby
well you did what you did was I mean you
know this is pretty brave what you did
but do you it's a party you regret it no
uh I mean I would probably work on it a
little bit more like you know like my I
think my lesson is because I wrote it at
4 P.M that's why I have a paper in my
hand and uh so maybe don't treat the
Kennedy centers your open mind
as a new material night well it was
powerful enough to get by without being
super Punchy I think so and I think also
it was it kind of came and went like I
think there's a six day news cycle and
if you can find a way to shut the [__]
up and just keep your phone away and not
counter the void yeah for six days
you'll be okay like come on school
shooting come on baby
so I just kind of went and and in that
moment you feel like you're the center
of the universe and you're really not
right yeah and so I think the
perspective is the uh of the of the
special is that is that if you can just
shut up and lie low love will find you
at the end of it and then
I think I discovered just what it means
to be a comic you know like it's been a
year since that happened but I'm like I
haven't given one interview I haven't
done the news never talked about the
content still don't intend to because
that's not my honor somebody else's
honored to critique the content
and I was like the first thing I write
about it has to be a joke hmm you know
because that's the only option a comic
has yeah you were called a terrorist by
BBC and like I mean really that's the
first joke I wrote yeah it was is March
and it happened in November you're a
first Terrorist on the show thank you
man not your last but but then I think
March I finally wrote down like I was on
the home page of the BBC and the BBC had
a headline that said comedian polarizes
the nation do you know how badly you
have to [__] up before the British say
that you divided it's a good job and
then I'm like okay this is the joke that
doesn't paint me as a victim addresses
that there's a [__] up and hopefully
makes both sides however you felt about
it laugh yeah and I'm like maybe that
can be the tone that's the goal of a
comic is to unify people in the room and
everyone laughs at it right and break
that tension but it's always so much
pressure when you have this big looming
thing and you're like I gotta write a
bit about it well dude I got some
strength from like just watching Chris
Rock for instance like you know in in
two weeks of what happened to him he's
like if you want to hear about my stuff
come see my special yeah but I'm not
going on Oprah and I'm not you know I'm
not doing any of that stuff so I was
like okay just shut up
and write jokes yes and it's also you
build it for your people not their
people yeah you go and your audience
will be supportive and I mean and your
audience grew like crazy from this right
it did yeah it did you almost have to do
something it's not in a way I would
recommend it's a very stressful way to
to gain traction so I wouldn't recommend
it but I think I don't know who said
this but maybe it was Louis CK or
someone who was like if you let somebody
who's never coming to see you [__] with
your head long enough that you are not a
hundred percent but like 80 for someone
who is coming to see you you're being
unprofessional ah I agree with that you
know so whoever is coming to see you you
owe them to send them home flying on a
cloud and I'm like I just have to
concentrate on making sure my brain is
okay to write jokes for big or small
whatever that crowd is coming to see me
here here it's crazy because some I mean
look you see the difference in countries
here like in America you we really We
complain about censorship but like we
get away with a lot you know oh yeah but
but I think you have your own version of
it right here like for me that's part of
the course in like a newer comedy Market
in India so many people watching were
watching stand up and now so many more
people are coming in and that's going to
be a first time reaction so not knowing
how to react to darker material or edgy
material or political material and
you've got to kind of Welcome them and
say okay every reaction is a valid
reaction uh in America I think because
you've been doing it a little bit you
know you're like but why this re because
everybody knows what stand-up comedy
Protocols are right and now you guys are
pivoting to a situation where the
audience's voice is as loud as you guys
I know I hate that uh which is it's a
tough pivot it's a bummer you know
that's just Twitter right yeah it just
everyone's got a voice they're yelling
out stuff a lot they yell stuff out but
it's like it almost keeps you sharp but
isn't that something that the two of you
have I always see your Clips is it like
a section of your show when you're done
with material and you're like okay now
you can talk to me yeah usually that's
what I do by the way should get a drink
out here a koi you're uh
this week
because you're a Guinness Drinker right
thank you sir you know I went to uh
Dublin to do a festival and they're like
you got to get the Guinness in Dublin
it's amazing same exactly the same
totally the same no difference okay
cheers Mazel
first terrorist
hopefully don't bomb
that's pretty good I like a Guinness
yeah oh yeah and this is a good uh it's
a good like first beer you go to the bar
you start with a Guinness and then you
kind of move on uh really that's a meal
right there like that you know I think
they say like the average Guinness is
like four slices of bread really don't
tell that to him he doesn't eat bread
what I'm off bread since when about
three days no no I've been doing about a
year trying and you're happy I feel
better yeah I mean I love pizza I love
sandwiches I love pancakes but I just
feel cleaner and you don't do like one
day a week where you go all out or
something like a rock cheat meal or
something that's crazy we'll break it
every now and then me and him will get
some waffles or something but it's like
once a month do we have this in
Bollywood movies we have the the
six-pack diet you know in a Bollywood
movie there's six songs right and
typically for one of those songs maybe
your shirt is off or whatever and that's
brutal as hell because that's
um six weeks no carbs
one week no salt what two days no water
what no water yeah and so you're
drinking like cold green tea just to
keep yourself like some liquid but it
passes through you quicker and you
everything will just crunch up you will
look amazing really but you will have
the strength of an ant
sort of dance in that moment or to do
like an intimate scene in that moment is
insane right but you look damn good on
camera so if you guys ever have to take
your shirt off on screen for anything
well he takes it off all the time yeah I
keep it on out of respect for all the
children out there right I don't want
them to look at my patchy hairy Jew body
yeah that was me last week you look
great dude can I eat some bread and
Pakistani for the record did he did he
have to do that though because I've read
like conflicting accounts where they
were like Camille you don't have to go
this far and he's like no I'm gonna keep
going but if you if there is I bet
Marvel's paying for it right yeah if
you're on their dime then it's kind of
cool to just get shredded and he's
always an extra mile guy even with his
comedy always yeah he went hard yeah hey
pamo what are you doing here hello
she works with beer oh I didn't know you
guys working together yes I thought you
popped in I feel like you're mad at us
right now yeah that's her General Vibe
all right Sit Down You're making us
nervous
oh my God
um what are we talking about Bollywood
so have you done those movies I've done
I've been in 14 Bollywood what yeah man
holy you're a vet huh I'm a vet yeah
what's the difference between that and
two of them were good will you do those
and then you do the Netflix movie The
Judd made like what's the difference
between those oh cash and uh and also I
mean bollywood's a different kind of
tone of acting and it's much tougher you
know because Bollywood you have to reach
an audience that is so gigantically
broad right and also uh you know I say
this often but don't think of a
Bollywood movie as uh you know you
giving two hours uh to a movie think of
a Bollywood movie as those are the only
two hours you get in the week so like
for me and my family like Sunday morning
the only time we got because everybody
works hard was two hours the entire
movie uh the entire family went out for
a movie so it's got to be big and bold
and Escapist and have a little bit of
every like if you show a spotlight we're
gonna kill ourselves right broad as hell
broad as hell and yeah and just really
magnanimous in my life it's like a road
comic you got a kill for everybody yeah
all like your Marvel movies you know I
think that's Marvel is your Bollywood ah
yeah a lot of six packs yeah revenge
stories ridiculous costumes yeah
beautiful coming back to life beautiful
hair do you get to play badass in any of
these uh yeah play the serial killer two
years ago I played a comic who's a
serial killer damn wow it's like a
shitty comic who needed to strangle
someone right before he went on stage to
get the juice to uh
but then he goes viral then he gets a
weekly show so now he has to strangle
somebody every week so bodies start
piling up around this film set and
nobody can figure out that it's the lead
guy a comic who goes viral how do you
prepare for this that happened in your
life well we had a serial killer comic
didn't we Bud champ really yeah he was a
rapist I don't think he was a killer Oh
I thought he killed people never mind
but he was they found him because of his
tour dates they noticed like somebody
was getting [__] over in every city
this is like his Andrew Tate pizza box
that was uh he's in Romanian prison
right now is that right is he not out I
would imagine
okay yeah he is the thing is like he is
a kickboxer he's probably holding his
own in there oh yeah and that uh comic
was on a serial killer but a Serial rape
okay sorry and he got caught because the
women's story started coming together
because after he would rape a woman he
would say pray for me and then right now
he had a catchphrase
what color is your Bugatti
yeah yeah but he was a clean comic too I
think they're always clean Yeah clean
guys Cosby Nate brigazi
wow we love you Nate Regan
[Laughter]
sorry
wait I got you off there no I was just
saying Johnny Carson oh yeah he was
apparently a big uh oh yeah a lot of a
lot of hitting the ladies really a lot
of throwing like whiskey whiskey glasses
at staff a legend yeah I just heard he
was hungry really that's the room up
yeah the experience that a guy from
Mumbai Across the Universe knows about
Johnny Carson's his massive dog yeah all
right Epstein was hung too but no he
wasn't uh in prison oh well I'm an idiot
yeah no because they though the whole
dock that likes an egg-shaped penis
that's right remember that yeah yeah hey
man look we got a bulge you know now
that eggs are harder to get is an
egg-shaped penis a little more
attractive what an egg-shaped penises
I'm just imagining foreskin isn't that
yeah a lot of foreskin yeah
very thin but yeah the Bollywood guys
man the hair Indians got the hair we
have the hair Whitey I thought had hair
on Lock and then Bollywood came along
and you guys took the but isn't it a
trade-off to just have hair later in
your life as well like I'd rather have
it I'd rather have hair longer
everywhere in my body for the rest of my
life yeah then kind of lose it early and
then not have it on my head of course
but you guys should have a hairy off
because uh are you really hairy guy you
got those Robin Williams forearms God's
been kind though I have four arms and
legs but like chest and junk is okay
let's go boys lift them up that's weird
that's not a sweater
no I'm a hairy guy oh yeah it's coming
out of the uh what do you uh oh yeah do
you do things about it or are you I
complain yeah but are you you're not
going like man waxing yeah who has the
time I've done that for a movie really
the full body I did it for a movie too
it was on YouTube yeah and uh no I had a
girl make me shave my chest uh in like
Kyle college and I was like oh that's
yeah she wants it shaved I'll do that
and then I like later I was like I felt
like violated yeah because she did that
and also when the stable comes out and
everything itches and then she's red
because you're lying down on top of her
and basically exfoliating you yeah I
hope that's why she's red yeah you're a
joofa yeah Jewish loofah all right that
was a stretch
my dad was super hairy and he shaved his
chest one day and I lost all respect for
him he's like heard our relationship
yeah because he was less of a man I
think as a kid I I couldn't look up you
just think like what [__] bogey ever
do that
would Humphrey Bogart shave his chest
now what about pubes where are you guys
at on the trim a trim yeah okay yeah I
like to do it on the road too so do I
that'll be their problem yes but that
with your disposal thing are you kind of
just leaving it in the shower or no no I
do it over the toilet I try to make as
little mess as possible and it never
works right no it's always like there's
a sprinkles stray stuff somewhere or the
other in the bathroom and why is there
always a pube at the urinal
[Laughter]
midday beer yeah it's a little warm
though huh what's going on here
[Laughter]
the entire thing becomes purple and it's
like a sweet Guinness really well we
gotta get that on the list I've never
heard of it what's the one with black
and tan what is that that's uh whiskey
and Guinness or something no I think
it's Yingling and Guinness isn't it then
there's a Stormy Daniels no dark and
stormy oh yeah that's rum though I think
that's right what's in the what is that
Sally
cider
don't you guys have your oh that's your
your whiskey right oh yeah our
whiskeycatwiskey.com I launched a bill
this year oh did you let's go [__] it I
like it is it really cool [__] it yeah
how do you spell it uh
f-a-a-a-a-k-i-t oh that's how I got
around the thing but the idea is you had
a good day [__] it he had a bad day [__]
it that's good I like that is it an
Indian Pale Ale uh no it is uh like I I
was like Bill alienates women and young
adults and just there's this sort of
Macho bear culture yeah and I want a
build that's halfway between Bill and
cider so it's not sweet but it's kind of
like a drink it at 11AM don't get [__]
up kind of a bill right right it's
called a happy bill and it's just called
[__] it yeah get it online I respect the
people that they're just getting loaded
on the flight that's my view good for
you man you're you're hustling right
this is great said the two guys with the
studio and whiskey in front of them wow
overseas though yeah we're gonna it's
gonna get there Bodega catwhiskey.com
but it's common man it's kind of this is
a hospital but you know and we got merch
now it's yeah people are loving the
bodega cat whiskey merch tried so hard
to be a guy who can handle oh like have
a palette for whiskey and I think like
my dad is a single malt guy and then I
just had a single Malton Coke once in
front of him and he was just like [__]
off you're never touching my whiskey
ever wow yeah that's a that's a bad move
because I did like a log of wool in 26
or something with like a Pepsi or
something like that oh my God no yeah
they get mad a lot of them people get
mad if you put an ice cube in there yeah
exactly I mean I'll I'll do it like one
Cube sometimes because I like it a
little chill but uh yeah let alone tab
whatever do you guys have an RC Cola and
uh Glen meringue have you guys done the
the factory tour ever like one of these
because you go to Scotland and they take
you around right to these these whiskey
places yeah the distilleries yeah I did
the I did the Heineken Brewery in
Amsterdam what a racket yeah don't ever
go oh my God it was so cheesy and
touristy why well they they it's the
original Brewery it's like right on the
canal so it looks cool then you go in
they hand you a beer and they're like
these are malts this is hops see you
later that's it yeah it's like so shitty
it's 40 bucks don't go that way it's
like the Hershey store in Hershey
Pennsylvania I went to that which I'm
which I've done which is another [__]
record yeah because hoshiz I'm sorry
America not great chocolate you know hey
don't you dare
[Music]
let's sing you know compare her she used
to like lint or Belgian chocolate or
German chocolate or really any chocolate
you know it's it's okay I had a good
time there I never did that tour you
know it's underrated the Pez Pez Museum
is unbelievable really yeah why it was
just great it's just so well done and
it's a cool layout and they got all the
old Pez from the 20s and the 30s really
fun I I maybe I didn't it's always about
where you were on the road and I was in
Hershey Pennsylvania so I was like oh
this is great yeah right it's better
than the shows I'm doing in the [__]
Motel yeah I was literally like in the
shittiest I was like ugly LaQuinta
across the street like I would kill to
be there in this dump just bombing with
Anthony DeVito he's just crying eating a
Hershey I was in Amsterdam and uh I was
on tour and the girl I was with we had
space cakes oh yeah and the guy at the
counter was like just have one and I'm
like [__] this we bought like two each
and had space cakes each and we were
staying at the Amstel Hotel on the
Amstel River we walked up and down the
river for four hours looking for the
river Wow
have you seen the Amstel River and
they're like it's right [__] behind
you and then we got kicked out of the
Museum of medieval torture I went to
that too right just because we were
taking photos like in the guillotine
yeah
that wasn't a bad Museum you know none
of that [__] is real by the way what
they build all of that stuff like
there's 17 of those museums it's like a
Madame Tussauds like they manufacture
the guilt the guillotine and just age it
up you know same thing with the
Holocaust Museum it's not real it's like
I went in I was like I thought this was
a this guy called Alex Jones at this
time
I love the five people were like was
that a joke
uh no it's uh you've been here for a
while though it's like what cities are
you liking versus not liking I like uh
okay my favorite club we were talking
about this but it's Zanies Nashville
yeah she's there today strong Indian
population which I need yeah and you
need your safety net but then there's
enough comedy fans who'll be like okay
if he's at Zanies he's probably good and
we'll go and see whoever the guy is
right so like that and you have jokes so
even if a random honky goes in there
you're still gonna laugh hopefully uh
there was a couple things I didn't
understand on the India thing but that's
literally in India speech yeah exactly
um but no I'm not at zany's Nashville
giving profound speeches that would not
be a great evening two India some kind
of cowboy hats like I don't I don't know
buy my beer at the end you guys like
cows right
um I love Chicago I love Chicago great
comedy town I think second best comedy
town in the country really New York
number one yeah I mean I did take my
last special there I love Chicago and
then yeah New York the cello you know
and then any I just the special was its
Cobalt but I've done like Town Hall a
bunch of times it's a good crowd how do
you feel when you first started working
the cell is the seller known to Indian
Comics No it's known to that comedy fans
yeah but for me it's
I mean I want to get better at tennis by
playing tennis with people who are
better than me you know so for me the
sellers were the best Comics are and it
took a while I'm not gonna lie like you
know when I first started working at The
Cellar and putting it out there just be
a lot of Indian people right and a lot
of the comics are like what's a lot of
brown people in the audience yeah and
you kind of that was Kevin Brennan
and then you kind of you know you build
your cred a little bit yeah oh yeah uh I
think I'm sorry let's think about New
York's I think you need the comics to
like you first and then the industry
catches on I think I it happened because
I followed Chris Rock oh yeah in
McDougall street I was in the basement
and Liz was there and he we were all
bumped and I just kind of watched his
new hour and then she was like they
didn't drop the check yet so go up and
do five and so I went up and did five uh
and until then I was guy from India who
sells Indian tickets and then I followed
I followed strong you know about five
and then that can be a good spot it's a
great spot where people [__] on it but
the crowd is so zoned in when you go up
and also they're playing with house
money if they're from out of town they
just saw Chris Rock yeah let's give the
next guy a shot and you're The Underdogs
you get to go up and go guys yeah I'm
trying here and if you would dress it
then the crowd is immediately on your
side as well so absolutely and then I
think she made me do it like three
nights in a row so
that was fun too but then you know I was
at the comic stable I think from that
point on did Chris watch at all no I
think he's there but his new stuff is
great it's great yeah he's got some
killer new yeah I can't wait to see what
he does about the Oscars I haven't seen
it yet I've seen it I cannot wait it's
pretty great yeah he keeps it silly
which is fun because you could tell he's
angry about it but it's very playful
sometimes you need that distance and and
I mean he's one of the best at taking
serious [__] oh yeah and making it silly
and fun you know dude he's doing it live
which is yeah what's that about it's
such a good idea you think so Regan did
it on Comedy Central a couple years yeah
the Comedy Central I mean well it'll be
a strong live show but like I've been
talking about this a lot as well like I
I think a stand-up special is very
different from a live show in that I
think a special is a piece of Cinema I
really do because you know I've been
waiting forever to have
a box on Netflix that is the same size
as Martin's courses box right and the
only thing I'm competing for is
attention so I do think a special now
has to be filmic and have like a
three-act structure and and have
silliness and discomfort and and a bunch
of stuff in it as well and so to see him
do that without any safety net of
editing or going back or retrospect Etc
like he'll have to pre-orchestrate that
show what if Will Smith is in the crowd
for the show just rushes The Stage like
you [__] this up that'd be a great
closer bring it all around but I think
you'll be able to do it I really do I
think so too yeah yeah I mean if anyone
can do it it's him and uh you know he's
been doing it for so long you know but I
once heard him say at the seller table
uh a new special needs a new feature you
know it should be like an iPhone it
should have a new feature and that's so
I think he I think he looks at specials
like something new should be
structurally he always says that that's
not a special that's a normal so he's
always trying to do some weird thing but
sometimes those can go too far like I
didn't think that Johannesburg thing was
that I would have rather just seen a
special throughout yeah I felt like it
gave away the trick a little bit yeah
yeah but the material is still great but
it's just yeah it's not my of his work
it's not my favorite same well I I mean
this special I know what you're saying
in terms of a new feature like I saw a
clip from The Prestige remember that
Nolan movie yeah right it was a movie a
two and a half minute clip right and
it's when Michael Caine is talking about
this uh the pledge and the turn and The
Prestige and to get from the turn to the
prestige you need misdirection so like
on that's what I base this entire
special on whoa but I'm like I'm gonna
arrive and I'm gonna you're gonna see
some sand and I'm gonna pour it on and
you're not gonna know what that is and
that's my pledge and then at some point
I'll keep showing you cuts of shoes that
you don't understand like random shots
of shoes which is misdirection and then
at the end of the special it revealed
that it's all Indians and yeah when I'm
standing on Indians so you can make fun
of India so I can make fun of India so
in the special whenever I'm making fun
of America I'm on American soil and
India is Indian soil but I don't reveal
it until like minute 55. well she sure
you want to say it here yeah it's fine
it's been out long enough okay okay but
what to call it Sandy Hook
was that real
according to the museum
uh remember when people said that there
were crisis actors that was Alex Jones
and he was like yeah they're crazy like
does that mean there's crisis actor
agents ah dude I she was in Pulse
Nightclub shooting this is a star right
here this is I've been dying to make
this movie I I met a a Mossad guy in
Singapore and he was telling me that
when Mossad conducted assassinations
they would um they would hire actors and
within like a one kilometer radius they
would write scripts for every one of
their actors so if it's just like man
and woman walking down the street with a
baby they'd write down an entire scene
for them whoa films script writers to
write scripts for the crowd during an
assassination that's a [__] movie
that's like Truman Show right a sales
script writer gets
something to like script assassinations
do those people know they're in an
assassination are they all suicide or
are they just like they hire actors they
hire actors damn those are good actors
populate the entire area with actors who
are basically doing lines wow damn I
mean that's below gay porn even you know
you're gonna really be struggling as an
actor to take that kid because you know
as scripted content goes gay porn
I don't know though you can at least
show your parents a tape of this ah good
point good point it's on the news yeah I
don't know yeah does India it is this
ignorant question but do you you know
you see the Bollywood it's very broad
it's very big music dancing are there
like Indian Saving Private Ryan oh yeah
okay the bulk of Indian movies are not
the big Bollywood spectacles you know I
think that's what gets noted like the
only two Indian things that get noticed
over here sort of big spectacle stuff
and then just sort of struggle movies
yes yes so lion and slum they put tails
in all of them uh and those movies get
noticed over here but movies like that
well received in India as well uh you
know because 99 of India is a
flourishing modern unsuccessful country
that wants a seat at the table you know
and so like 99 of movies talk about that
but you don't really see that so much
interesting and then you have like I
don't know if you ever get a chance
please watch the trailer of a movie
called Basmati Blues which exemplifies
everything Iraq it's where Brie Larson
one of my favorite Indian actresses
right oh it's wonderful a white lady
comes down to India and teaches us how
to make rice
so is it good actually good or you [__]
no okay all right so oh that's
embarrassing what what about uh
so there's part of your special where
you say oh yeah hold on let's watch this
first let's see
oh I like Donald Sutherland though yeah
a boy you know she was so excited for
this role I'm gonna be a hero
[Laughter]
very the sequel in North Korea was even
worse
I don't even like leaving my own
neighborhood oh man
thank you
I'm sorry even the crisis actors turned
this one down
biology ah this is this is gonna put a
Juno soundtrack
oh we got the cool hot Indian guy yeah
there's gonna be some uh interracial
love here
but you know we met once before on the
train I was on the roof it's only
chemicals ah this is this is grossing me
out I can't watch it's too cheesy I like
to go can't get it up he's like sorry
our next partner is athletic greens ag-1
by athletic greens was the morning
booster I needed just scoop shake and
have alongside your morning coffee or OJ
it's like taking the shelf of
multivitamins in one drink I love this
stuff uh I had some today you know we're
on the road you did I did it's it's
actually tastes pretty good I need that
immunity baby yes we're on the road
we're eating Panda Express and [__]
it's horrible diet you need the greens
we're not getting enough vegetables so
it's a perfect substitute just shove
that right up your ass it tastes solid
it's real and uh I love it packed with
over 75 vitamins and minerals for a
major boost right to the gut it helps
the mood the energy even skin hair and
nails it's the healthiest thing you can
do in under a minute tell that to my
wife if you're looking for an easier way
to take supplements athletic greens has
given you a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to athletic
greens.com drunk that's
athleticgreens.com
drunken check it out
nothing makes you sound smarter than
learning a new language Babble is a
language learning app with easy
bite-sized language lessons uh I mean
this is we all want to learn another
language we've had people like verdas on
here who sound cultured as hell oh yeah
it's always nice to know another
language you go to another place you
don't have to go speaky American
because what I do currently so get on
Babel you know lessons take as little as
10 minutes a day so you start having
real life conversations in as little as
three weeks choose from 14 different
languages with lessons voiced by real
native speakers not computers with Babel
you can access podcasts Games videos
stories and even live classes to help
you on your way plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee right now
get up to 55 off your subscription when
you go to babble.com drunk that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash drunk for up to 55
off your subscription Babble language
for life oh baby
there we go all right that was a
squeaker The Look
of Love
is up your butt
all right save time and have the energy
you need to tackle everything on your
to-do list with factors ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
Factor shops preps cooks and delivers to
your door so you can enjoy Chef crafted
dietitian approved minus the hassle they
sent me a bunch of these things they
taste great there's all kinds of
different flavors fish steak chicken
with veggies and sides I loved it and
they give you these smoothies too you
just get a big assortment of fruit
smoothies you got the greens you got the
berry you got the veggie with calorie
smart and keto options Factor meals are
perfectly portioned to keep you on track
with your goals with over 34 meals per
week and over three dozen add-on options
each factor meal arrives pre-prepared by
their chefs come on ready to heat and
eat in two minutes
head to factormeals.com
drunk60 and use code drunk60 to get 60
off your first box that's a lot that's
code drunk 60 at factormeals.com
drunk60 to get 60 off your first box
Factor get on it
so you're talking about uh in the
special you're talking about there's a
line you have where you say uh you know
hate is is yell but love is felt yeah
yeah I mean that's like that was kind of
a profound line you know I mean because
you've dealt with so much [__] yeah and
you talk about feeling suicidal in this
nice hotel you because you nominate for
an Emmy the same night that you're
called a terrorists mixed feelings yeah
mixed feelings rough night rough night
Bittersweet but I tried to do a suicide
bit that kind of got to the laugh really
quick yeah were you really that low or
it was an end for sure yeah but I mean
oh suicidal comedian you're really
special
let's be honest so what I will say is
that aside any day you get to tell
people your problems on Netflix is a
pretty good goddamn dude life's all
right right uh but I think that's part
of it as well that if you hate is always
going to be louder and it's always going
to Trend and it's always going to be
number one and and it's very easy to
assume that that's all the feedback
coming at you yeah and that's what now
paints you right and you discover that
most people are sensible and want to pay
their bills and go to bed at night and
will not go out of their way to yell
love at you yeah uh but then suddenly
eight months later when you go out on
tour again they'll come and buy your
ticket and they'll come and see you with
genuine empathy and and they'll be
[__] awesome about it yeah but you
just kind of have to hang out and wait
for the light to hit you yes you know
that's a journey there is a weird I know
it's a quote there's a fine line between
love and hate it's so true if someone
hates you that much they gotta care
about you yeah a little bit uh because
some people are like what do you uh you
hate this group you're like I don't even
think about that group I don't care
about the group enough to hate it yeah
you always think of that Howard Stern
line from private parts where they say
people that hate you listen uh twice as
long twice as long yeah what they say
people like you listen for an hour and a
half how much people hate you listen to
two hours right they both want to hear
what you're going to say next yeah but I
find that on either side you know uh
large professions of of hate or love say
more about the person than this the
person they're talking of course here
here you know oh yeah when I when
someone is writing really hateful [__]
to me on social media I'm just like this
is you this is not yeah for me to elicit
this I'm going to guess you're not in
therapy right I'm gonna guess you're not
uh someone who takes a hard look it's
easier to hate outward than to look
inward totally totally and I also think
hate or love large expressions of it
come from a certain loneliness you're
like yeah it's sort of going is anybody
else with me on this and can we be part
of a tribe together we do it all the
time you're in the bank and someone's
taken forever in line you look you look
for someone to make eye contact with to
be like this guy huh yeah this [__]
ass we're all just looking for the
connection yeah but you also you ever
have a guy say something really mean on
Twitter and I'll like it and they go ah
I'm sorry man I was [__] around I
love you and you're like crushed me but
99 of those guys if you met them on the
street would be really cool I know I I
I'm not arrogant enough to say like I
don't read the comments so it doesn't
get to me it totally gets to me and I I
will go down a rabbit hole of saying of
you know cringe sort of all the hatred
and all of that stuff I will go down
that rabbit hole I regret riding those
but you know but also you talk about the
difference like when when people in
America talk about getting canceled by
like a Twitter mob and you're like I'm
on the [__] news yeah I mean that's
but but again like
who said this like the worst thing that
ever happened to you is the worst thing
that ever happened to you you know so I
wouldn't judge an American company I
think that was Cosby also right I am
like
why do we keep going from here
but he's in the news again I can't I
can't stop people are going to that tour
that's like selling out they better
bring a pillow that one but is he gonna
talk I've studied a bunch of black
Comics like he's going to talk about it
so he's he's going to be on stage like
so the first [__] testified yeah I'm
sure it's weird
just downtime
um but no I don't judge anybody harshly
for that it's a joke right where yeah
it's cute uh that you complain about
cancer culture or sort of a I do think
the oh can I say this or can I not say
this bit that all Comics we're now doing
yeah so that's gonna outrun its time I
agree yeah just say it also you're
saying it yeah you are and also I think
I don't know where the line is and
thinking about it is going to drive me
insane yeah how about I'll do the joke
and you let me know where the line is
yeah the audience and then you know and
then you did the two India speech you're
like that was a lot but no I'll work
with you from that point on yeah I'm not
any feedback is good feedback as long as
it doesn't translate into hate or
threats is good feedback if people can
actually have a problem with the Twitter
and stuff like that is there's no nuance
and there's no attempt at a dialogue
yeah no there's actually a conversation
to be had then it's actually it can be
enlightening and interesting and not
cancel culture counsel culture oh
but
that's a good thing to say when someone
gives you feedback after a show I should
have confetti uh but you're right about
showing the audience shows where the
line is and that's all good and well but
let me learn what the line is and then
don't ruin me for trying to find where
the line is yeah that's my thing I think
artists deserve the opportunity to be
imperfect without systems coming crashed
yes for merely imperfect and for you it
built your audience I mean it made you
right you went through this you know
kind of traumatic thing that now you are
playing bigger venues I am and also it's
a weird thing right because you're not
gonna come out on stage because now
people are coming out to see you with a
slightly more emotional connection they
are and they're invested in your story
so you you cheat them if you don't talk
about it as well sure it's the the first
thing they're thinking when they see you
is I know what you've gone through I was
kind of with you on it so you do have to
talk about it but my rule was very
simply the first word I say about it has
to be [__] funny I love that you know
that's otherwise I'm not a comic yes you
know here I'll tell some other Comics
working today that well yeah Jesus
Christ we get it you're molesting no
let's talk about all of them one of my
one of my least favorite one-man shows
by the way
that's the other thing I was I was
talking about with somebody is you know
comedies now I think comedians are
learning to play the camera a little bit
sure you know because like a specialist
like here you know it's not a big
theatrical show so sometimes you see a
special where a comic is talking about
something very intimate but he's like my
dad died right right he's trying to
reach like the third layer of the
audience but the camera is right there
right right I think we're learning now
this is gonna be like my dad died you
know and keep it in but I also think
breaking through like you're too Indie
is broke that kind of what broke you and
that's pretty standard like real
specials before that I mean but but this
but this took it to another level more
than any of this stuff it's that you
can't predict stuff I no you're doing
the pandemic
I was depressed and wanted to do stand
up so I ended up
um like grabbing a speaker and a
microphone and climbing up a hill to a
forest near my house in Goa and 35
people would come out and we'd sit in
the sunlight and do stand up at 3 P.M
yeah with a PA that I set up myself yeah
and I did five YouTube videos about the
world as such so they were about uh
cancer culture freedom of speech
privilege in the west comedy versus
religion and death right and the idea
was can I create
five or ten pieces of Comedy that are
you know about the world
those five videos move the needle more
than like yeah
see
there's no predicting what people also
people needed content too yeah like I
did a few videos in Central Park I'm
bombing under a tree with seven people
you know sitting on the grass and that
one did well too yeah because it was
just like this is what they're going
through man these guys are diehards yeah
I think it showed people how much we
needed well a lot of people dropped off
during the pandemic yeah they got rid of
some of those people and we're going
they weren't willing to do anything like
that yeah right that is but the point is
you you just don't know you can shoot
the most expensive special in the world
you can and then what you don't need to
do by the way when certain comments will
tell me how much they spent on a special
I was like you do realize that all you
really need is you and the mic yeah yeah
we don't need a [__] swinging shot
from a chandelier you know it's like a
bit much work on the act more than the
production what about how scared were
you when you were home I mean how how
not so much I I think we had a
but it's not my first rodeo you know in
terms of I've been doing this a while
and also I think you
when you have a you know God's been
kinds you have a larger audience it's
par for the course so I was scared but I
was more scared for
a family that hadn't signed up for this
you know like my wife I'm like I want to
make sure they're okay that's tough you
know I'm very privileged so I have a
good legal team I you know we'll be okay
in that sense what did your wife say
when this happened did you run the
speech buyer before yeah my wife heard
it at like 4 P.M because I literally
loaded at 4 pm and then we found a
wedding photographer who was unemployed
on a Sunday and he shot it wow good job
my wife I was like should I do this and
she's like yeah that's a good one I love
that she's been a trooper man it's not
been an easy nine months but she's uh
you know we've hung in there but it
makes it hotter it's like sexier you're
like uh
come on
a guy lying in bed like I think I [__]
up
good point good point you're just the
hotel how'd you let me do this you [__]
no women need safety security and some
level of masculinity yeah you know so
yeah sure I hear you well I'm working on
that last one but
but Bill Burr he did the Philly rant and
he walked off stage and he goes well my
career's over and then that's what
propelled it have you seen that the
building I have yeah but again like I
thought my career is over three times
you know so I I once did a
a Bollywood movie that was like a like
an American Pie sex comedy kind of a
romp and it's called mastizaade and it's
uh you guys may know her may not but her
name is Sunny Leone and she used to be a
porn star and then she became a
Bollywood actress and it was me and her
this gigantic Studio Movie damn uh that
I was packaged as one of the two leads
and uh
blatantly a movie that everybody did for
cash yeah and would not watch ah and you
and the phone stopped ringing for a good
year what was like the peak gross out
scene you said it's like an American Pie
they [__] a pie I'm guessing you didn't
[__] a samosa so like what's the what's
like the gross out scene in the movie
humped a horse really yeah you you
humped a horse I think I humped a horse
yeah you know so it's just me
a guy behind me and he's kind of humping
me while I hump a horse uh and the tail
is like flapping me in the face and I
was like yeah I went to drama school
we have a movie called horse it's very
different where a guy humps a horse no
that's not the one don't click that
so no and Freddie Got Fingered he jerks
off an elephant doesn't it that's right
and a horse and a horse but
um
m-a-s-d-i-z-a-a-d-e but the point is
like at that moment in time you're like
yeah I deserve this it's gonna be a dip
and then hopefully you know your
I'll find it and we'll come back like
you it you gotta find these kind of Ebbs
and flows yeah did you read your wife
that script at 4pm no no I did not no
okay no but what was the porn star like
she was amazing really she's intelligent
funny [__] amazing all right yeah
mastizard yeah we shouldn't dwell on
this all right all right we'll move on
but it's [__] up the car you musty
yeah but
oh wow look how big this is it's so uh
it's magnanimous right yeah
it does definitely have that American
Pie
here we go
[Music]
this looks kind of fun
movie it's just terrible yeah you're
telling me but I'd watch this at a hotel
room on a Friday before a gig both you
on tour this weekend this is something
special watch this
wow all right well good for you you got
to take a swing you know there you go
Yeah man so I mean that's how do you
make the decision to be like I'm on a
tour in America
uh musties are they actually don't stop
ringing and then I met these guys who
were down from an American agency and
they kind of found a clip of mine and
they're like we want to sign you so come
to LA and take meetings which means give
money to Uber and get free water and I
showed up and like I had been neglecting
stand up I want to say for like seven
years or eight years how long have you
been doing stand-up this is your 16.
okay and uh
I went to the Laugh Factory and I had a
eight minute spot and I think I followed
Whitney and she killed hard I followed
strong and I just kind of fell in love
with it again man I was like I feel more
fulfilled by this than I have in the
last five movies and I'm like I'm just
gonna start working America So Adam sent
me out so I spent a year traveling
America just kind of see what stand-up
was doing so people in India why are you
in a daze in yeah like what clubs what
kind of cities were you hitting were you
doing weekends yeah I was doing like
Charlottesville Huntsville Alabama
you know just doing the roles stand up
live and Hunt yeah and like improvs I
was with levity so so improv so largely
what I was playing nice I did Caroline's
a bunch of times yeah and just kind of
R.I.P Carolines we love you yeah man uh
damn there's there's Indians around yeah
man because uh Huntsville has NASA so
yeah you need smart people so I just
can't I needed to learn what stand-up
was again yeah but it's the best you
know a lot of it sucks that it's the
gutter of Show Business you know like
these old actors are like I'm out of
money I'll go
tell some stories on stage about those
80s movies I was in is are there a lot
of actors doing stand-ups oh I feel like
it's kind of the lowest pit but like you
can make money at this so they're like
oh their agents are like you should do
stand up because you can sell the
tickets Oh I thought when you use a
point in your special where you're like
you know you're going through all this
[__] and you those are your lawyers
your agents were like money and you're
like my life you know yeah I mean that's
like I remember doing a gig years ago uh
it was at the Mall of America in uh
Minneapolis Minneapolis and it was a
Fallout week and I was like I needed
work but also like you know I was I was
working every week but like I had an
open weekend they're like someone just
dropped out this weekend in the Mall of
America Minneapolis it's yours you
should do it and uh I was like the same
the same Mall of America that all
shababs just threatened to shoot up this
week and maybe that's why I dropped out
though like we haven't heard about that
I was like go to cnn.com that's the
first thing they're talking about ah
those are actors
well I text Joe list he goes if you take
it and get murdered you're officially
the dumbest [__] on the planet ah yeah
[__] but you took it I didn't oh you
didn't take I didn't I was like I'll
just do sellers I'd seller spots I was
like I'll just do the next no I've never
played that room yeah it's not it's huge
I think my low was uh TV shopping
at some point and you would be surprised
how much money it is like it's a lot of
money so you do it because you have no
money yeah and then it is literally nine
times what you think you're gonna get
paid so I get why people started and
then stay but it's literally like how
much do you think this plasma TV costs
like send us a message now and we'll
give you a deal I was that guy wait two
months Oh I thought you meant shop on a
show no you're literally selling TVs
yeah man what TVs mixers uh necklaces
like just you know you have a shopping
channel right yeah yeah it's that guy
how how many years in the stand up was
this this was maybe pull it up four
years into a Bollywood career uh but
they probably paid you well to do this
stuff man it's it's a ton of money wow
and they just see like we like this guy
he's got this cool TV well by the TV
that's their logic no I mean the guys
who produce it as like no his career
just died
and then they they give you enough to
stay well you have a good attitude I
mean you know it's uh it's like he's
hosted a game show yeah probably
something like that I could never host a
like
I've been told any time I've ever hosted
anything I come off as sarcastic ah yeah
same like I'll do a corporate gig once
in a while but after MC and it's a ton
of money but then I'm just like please
welcome okay right please that's how I
was when I used to hand out flyers on
the street is people would uh they'd be
like this is the [__] level of
enthusiasm you have for your show yeah
yeah I'd be like I mean yeah I'm out
here five hours in the cold yeah what do
you want for me have you guys done the
the Edinburgh Fringe Festival yet I tell
you you have to really everyone says
that I've got some mixed reviews on it
so it's not I mean you will need like a
it depends on what you want if you want
to work out your show get your ass
whooped and have an audience teach you
something every night and then watch
enough art that pisses you off that it
clicks something in your show yeah
that's a good reason to do it but if
you're looking to like succeed or PR and
all of that stuff then you need a very
narrative based you know kind of a show
you have to tell your story Pam you're a
PR person do we have to do Edinburgh
yeah I don't want to do it I I feel like
I can get the same workout just doing
the road in New York or in in the
country 29 shows in 25 days
a one-man show no I'm not although I do
have this great show idea about being
molested
it's called Uh daddy
the diddler
yeah everybody I mean it's beautiful
Daddy diddler yeah dude you got to see
this show I loved it oh really like I
did I've never done a full run before I
was in a basement 90 people in the
basement and for the first two weeks
you're like what the [__] am I doing
yeah and then something happens in the
third week where suddenly your whole
show changes like I went in with the
show that wasn't ready and it was ready
by the time I came out because you just
it's every night it's every night but
then I was watching like nine things a
day wow that would make me crazy though
yeah I wasn't watching stand up I was
watching like every other thing yeah
okay like can you watch stand up it's
hard I can I like it it's very hard for
me to watch sand it's got to be good you
know it's got to be like oh Neil
Brennan's got a special he's a good
writer I'll watch that yeah I'll watch
it here and there but I yeah I don't I I
don't like watching stand up I like to
watch movies that's kind of like my
Escape because it's not like what we do
I'm at the club the sauce
yeah that's true but some every once in
a while I'll get I'll be I'll see
someone new and I'll be like oh wow that
was awesome so that that feeling is
really is great when you discover
someone new who you like but uh but
isn't that what's great about this
profession that On Any Given [__]
night the the kid with five years in can
outdo yes the guy with videos and it
happens and we've been I've been on both
sides of that sure you know we're
sometimes like I just killed harder than
that guy than than some new twink blows
me off the stage and I'm like yeah
that's what we've got Chris Rock so good
you've heard that story no he was a off
SNL he's kind of fizzling out he's doing
a gig in the road Martin Lawrence is
opening Martin Lawrence annihilates
Standing Ovation roof comes off and
Chris Rock comes out there and kind of
eats it and he's like I gotta I gotta
kick it up a notch we've all had that
guy open for us we were like [__] that's
why I bring Gary veterans never a
problem
no uh but we uh we all have had that guy
we were like what the sometimes it's a
high energy comic the worst is when
they're nothing like you yeah we're all
pretty well none of us are high energy
acts and when you get someone who's a
high energy like a yeller and they've
got good material yeah it's like and
they're dirty like they've got
everything they've got some gimmicks
maybe a music cue a dance number they
fall over oh God that's worse of course
the first night you're always kind of
like ah he did pretty well second night
you're like he's he's really kind of
bearing me at night three you're like
give it up for the hack everybody yeah
exactly give it up for the [__] hack
on this tour I did a strange thing where
I use single songwriters
7 Series in India and I was just like if
you're a kid if you're unsigned and if
you have over a certain amount of views
on YouTube but like under a certain
amount as well where you truly like need
the platform yeah show up
You'll Play while people are sitting
down so the minute house opens you're on
I'll give you 25 minutes but I'll film
your [__] and I'll send it back to you
there you go and uh like I think six of
those guys have gotten signed yes you're
helping out a lot of young Comics but uh
they were single songwriters like
focusing on singers and like you would
be surprised
how cool A vibe it sets like if you can
walk into a stand-up show and it's not
like some obnoxious DJ [__] but it's
just like some you know John Mayer Vibe
yeah somebody's just playing while you
sit down it's a great Vibe well Mark and
I both used to open for Amy Schumer and
she had her brother was in a jazz and
set such a good vibe it was like a very
classy thing for people to walk into
this major show yeah with the you know
these really good jazz killer Jazz yeah
I filmed zarna's set at Caroline's and
she had someone playing like a
traditional Indian oh really talking
about like 15 minutes that's really cool
oh wow and it did set a cool tone I
thought about it
she's a beast man like she always kills
me sometimes and you know and she comes
out and my crowd's really young and
everybody's like oh Indian Auntie yeah
and she says content under 30 seconds
and everybody's like [__] yeah let's go
yeah she's working so hard too she's
just grinding and grinding I'd love to
see that and she's what three years in
foils in is she yeah wow so I I I don't
want to misstate some I think she's
under seven years oh for sure you know
definitely which is for grateful to be
at that level she'll get a sitcom or
something I mean she's perfect for that
yeah I think so it's coming or Bollywood
these are not Crusher in Bollywood sex
comedy yeah you know there is a vacancy
now
she's on too
Electric
oh dude even Sinatra [__] hit a low
point you got to remember like before we
did that that what's that movie he won
the Oscar for Nigerian Channel no the
other one the Bert Lancaster one out of
Africa you're very old Hollywood right
like that I love Hollywood yeah we're so
smart and so is Matt to be honest I mean
Salamanca but uh he won the Oscar for it
he dies in it he's in the military yeah
yeah it's a war movie
no no I was watching uh have you guys
seen uh [__] with the offer on Paramount
plus I like about the Godfather I read
the book it's a great it's called the
leave the gun take the cannoli great
book so just the way they do Sinatra and
that is hilarious really he was so
against The Godfather right all the
gangsters [__] hated it yeah and that
Johnny Fontaine is supposed to be Frank
Sinatra right right so he kept kind of
riling up people so that the movie
wouldn't get made and then they had to
go sit down with Sinatra and be like
here's why he's not based on you then
the movie gets made and everybody's like
that's Sinatra yeah is that a man with
golden arm yes no no you've heard
something won here
do you want twice you tell me one twice
supporting that Sinatra is apparently a
big [__] like he wouldn't he was
divorced uh what's her face over
Rosemary's Baby Mia Pharaoh he was also
like 60 and she was 21. I'm like what
are you doing I know but like how do you
have a conversation
I've heard a great story of him like
slapping a sound engineer in a studio
who apparently was Indian which is how
it got to me but he was a mix engineer
uh the Will Smith and and Sinatra goes
in does it take and he's smoking and his
voice is a little raspy and he kind of
does the entire song in one take yeah
and then they all just like we need
another take and they send the new guy
out to tell senato you gotta do it one
more time and he just kind of says come
here
slaps him across his face and says
retakes it for [__]
by the way from here to Eternity
how'd I beat you to go [__] what the
[__] oh let's tune up the story here all
right so you hear that Don Rickles story
when he said he'd uh you ever hear that
time that Frank Sinatra saved my life he
said okay boys that's enough
that's great damn Rickles is good
Sinatra really was just like a weird
character dude he hated Elvis speaking
of guys coming up who are younger Elvis
was like the hot new thing and he was
like what the [__] is this but he hit he
was like came up this like you know the
Hoboken hummingbird just like pretty boy
then it becomes kind of grizzled and
cool and yeah and Mobby and you guys see
the Elvis movie did you like it I didn't
see it it was well done really just for
personal reasons because I think
everybody has a kernel in their life
like you know every artist growing up
has that [__] leech that finds you
when you're young and you gotta shake
him off oh yeah so I was just watching
it for that reason I'm like I'm I've had
seven of these guys in my life so I
don't have to like move on it was an
early Bollywood film
but that's uh yeah I I think the problem
with the Elvis movie The reason I see it
there's two there's too many biopics
and there's too many True Crimes right
now no there's a lot of True Crimes the
biobooks I liked what's his name in the
Rami Malik and Bohemian Rhapsody was in
incredible I thought but uh yeah I
thought they over did the teeth I
thought so too because oh and also the
age when he just said I got it uh yeah
you might have to be more specific
I think you're referencing like Dick Van
Dyke Poppins or something
but yeah the office movie was cool but
uh it was so stylized I don't know but
it's it's a cool story but that's his
that's his thing right bazlerman yeah
yeah yeah is he good
I can't tell if he's good yeah it's like
a [__]
movies
is a lady boy an artistic [__] yes
exactly like am I into this I don't know
kind of yeah that's how he is that's my
favorite thing about playing like
Thailand is just watching old British
men holding hands with ladyboys walking
through the market not making eye
contact with each other
I gotta go to Thailand
can we take a quick pee break oh come on
I'm dying dude I [__] had like four
coffees before this I'll talk [__] about
you when you go oh yeah keep going all
right finally okay tell me South Africa
all right boy it was Unreal we did
Amsterdam first did some drugs by the
way don't do don't do mushrooms in
Amsterdam yeah
they're called they're truffles okay so
some American jumped off a roof on
mushrooms so they they made them illegal
and I feel like the American might not
have needed the mushrooms yeah
I know
right so he jumped off so now they're
Truffles and I was like oh wow that
sounds fine it's probably different over
here and I ate them and it was hell just
put me to bad mood big mistake so
Amsterdam was kind of a bust but then we
flew right to Cape Town and had a
[__] blast it is supposed to be
magnetically the best energy place in
the planet is that right yeah like
people say like just magnetic energy in
Cape Town you will feel better than you
feel anywhere in the world totally well
if it was rainy and cold we went to Cape
Town it was sunny and 80 degrees and uh
you know I love segregation it was great
no I'm joking but it was uh super fun I
mean the poverty there is bananas yeah
but uh do you fly into Cape Town or do
you fly into Soweto or 12 hours coach
because I'm a psycho and uh 12 yeah okay
on which airline uh it's called air link
real trash okay don't do it and uh yeah
we just had a great time and the Rand
everything's in Rand yeah and it's so
cheap you know it's like this is 450
Rand you're like Jesus and that's like
and they were overcharging you anyway
yeah yeah that's like 38 or something
did you see in like Champs Bay or Camp's
bill I stayed right on the Harbor but it
was it was a five minute drive to camps
Bay we did that every day and just the
sun was out we'd have beers on the beach
it was great and then did you did you
see like big cats and stuff like that
did you do the Safari I did the Safari
uh we flew to uh Mozambique and then
drove two hours through the jungle and
it was it was life-changing nice I grew
up in Africa I grew up in Nigeria oh I
didn't know that and that's kind of home
for me 17 years whoa why huh my dad my
parents can smell when I'm happy
but when I was my dad was making tomato
pulp and uh pre-cut potato chips in
Lagos Nigeria wow and
then I went to boarding school in India
when I was nine but Nigeria was home for
like the first 17 years wow do you speak
uh I speak a little bit of Yoruba and a
little bit of like pigeon English boy
you are [__] cultured yeah
can you do their accent like when they
speak English I do it in the special a
little bit I like uh it's the pigeon
English is kind of English that was
spoken so that the English wouldn't know
what was being said
you know so if it is uh I'm gonna go
have some lunch it's like I'll go chop
now
oh it's almost like Ebonics yeah like
it's like slang yeah so it's you know so
that I speak a little bit
damn what's up they're wonderful like
Nigeria I think is one of the most sort
of badass yeah uh Just Energy flying
sexual fun places on the planet oh
really do you ever go back uh yeah uh I
go back sort of once every three years
people in Lagos can party man it's a
hell of a place and comedy is just
getting there they have a comedy club in
Kenya now and uh I think in Nigeria
but it's coming so let me ask one
question so what's your type are you
straight yes
women or do you like Indian women like
what's your like this is my thing
because like they don't feel like what
you can grow up with is liking Nigerian
and Indian women are very similar Ron
hot very emotional very intelligent uh
and don't take [__] at all so
but I uh I've dated a Nigerian girl and
I've married an Indian girl oh damn that
works yeah both at the same time yeah I
know yeah
wow well it's it's funny because Indians
got hot you know growing up in the 80s
it was like top what was that [__]
Johnny Five
what's that guys no no uh with the robot
short circuit yeah and I don't think I
don't even think he was Indian
I don't think he was and then he had a
poo it was a little brown face or
something I think it was that guy yeah
Fisher Stevens Fisher Stevens no I had
so many Indian Stevens out there that
was Brown face guys this is Justin
Trudeau uh thing and then you got Cal
Penn kind of came in and I think you
know you got your knee meshes and your
Veer doses yeah Indian women have always
been hot always but the problem is the
distance between Indian women and Indian
men and vanities is gigantic is it yeah
yeah because like I don't know
Scandinavian people the women are as
good looking as the men would say that
right whether you find them good looking
or not I prefer the women but yeah yeah
but like Indian women are beautiful in
Indian men are with them
[Laughter]
because he's a he's got a jawline Disney
prince that guy yeah big eyes big hair
I've never heard of that and that makes
so much sense it's funny when your
friend just reveals they find another
man very attractive because he is but
the guy a Disney prince is such a
specific oh yeah well I think about him
a lot
but he's coming on here at some point
we're going to get him yeah we got to
get him on here yeah he's a sweet guy he
did my other pot he did my games with
names pod because we got Mike Bibby on
who's his favorite basketball player you
guys had his Ease on no he doesn't think
he's a Disney prince huh
Aziz doesn't do podcasts yeah not really
not really I mean we got Colin Quinn on
who really doesn't do podcasts that's
true and David tell and we got a tell on
who's both of them Disney Princesses
I don't like the old man in the tree
I'm at hotel for 10 seconds at the
cellar yeah it's pretty good yeah he saw
me and he was like
and he walked away and I was like I
think that was good that's good yeah how
familiar were you with a towel before
coming to New York I I knew what was
that show Insomniac yeah so that was on
when I was in college in the states so I
remember him from that but I I was
ignorant to the comedic Legacy at the
cello he's our goat Kinda Yeah and I
think of the shallow there are these
things right there's the comedians table
and then you earn your space at that
table and he saw I learned all of that
stuff right you know well put a p on it
it's Patel
yeah true all right he's right he's
right there
yeah
comedy it was a nice 10 seconds
everybody thinks the tell hates him and
uh he's the sweetest guy he's just a
little fidgety yeah he is he is like a
bodega cat guy who just keeps working a
plug for his products yeah he's grumpy
he's kind of like a cat yeah you know
sometimes you just have to say [__] it
you know
everybody
but it's always like a cat where you're
just kind of like grateful you're like
all right pet and then he just like runs
away oh yeah I got a second with him
yeah you just you got to let him come to
you like yeah he's got to rub your leg
for me head movements everything in
terms of feedback because especially
with comics and even in in like movies
or whatever if somebody comes out of a
screening or somebody comes out of uh
watching you I find that if they do this
it's sort of up and down you did good
irrespective of what they say but if
they ever go like you know like it's
ever side to side yeah they'll say
something nice but you're [__] up you
know it's always like those costumes
amazing
oh this is a piece of [__] that's so
true those costumes I mean my outfit am
I special Seinfeld had that funny bit
about how you can tell how bad a
relationship's going by how high they
touch their face you know I was like
how's it going with that girl it's going
pretty good or it's like I gotta get out
that's great that's an oldie speaking of
[__] our guess has to go on 15. so can
we do bits or peeps oh oh yeah yeah do
you have any bits or peeves any peeves I
have peeves oh please okay I these are
very pretentious but
I do not like a hotel
where the staff is cool like the hotel
desk guys cool and calls you bro this is
a specific one but you know like like I
don't know so whole house or something
oh like the W but they're like hey bro
well I'm like no at this price it's Mr
Das
recording this Instagram
I cannot stand that we're not friends
also yeah like let's not go right to bro
I'll never see you again so where does
that come from bro is I have a bro there
you go he's my brother but there are
these like I think the the 60 range of
hotels like 60 Las yes or like so I also
the W it's always like some cool guy who
has as many Instagram followers as
YouTube right right and it's like hey
man what's up and I'm like no I cannot
do that I don't know why yeah what do
you think it is do you think it makes
you feel less cool that he's being cool
or what is it it's so not genuine yeah
not genuine that's what it is yeah you
can just like he says that to everybody
don't make me feel special that's what
it is I feel like he would have more fun
in that hotel room
you know like that's the guy the room is
meant for right he's sending me over
that's one um that's a good one I don't
like guys with
uh Baba done builds
Puerto Rico if it's way too shaped and
way too sharp I can't do it I'm with you
right yeah because they it's a
narcissism thing yeah like you want to
keep you want to look in the mirror for
a while and make it perfect
I'm with you I like the one side you
know like yeah I like I like a DIY build
I feel the same way about guys who are
really into their birthday like if a guy
doesn't notice it's his birthday I like
that guy you know a guy like oh yes my
birthday the guy's depressed yeah that's
my No but I'm with Mark on this one when
someone's like it's my birthday week I'm
like I guess I gotta come up with seven
excuses now [__] you ah yeah yeah where
do you stand on gender reveal videos and
parties because that seems to be a
uniquely American I don't I don't know
anyone who would do that so that's the
thing where like it doesn't it doesn't
affect me yeah yeah like there's a lot
of deaths with those like a lot of [__]
catches on fire because they always try
to be really extravagant pull it up yeah
you can't tell if it's blue or uh
because it's red now you know so by the
way in in India Africa many other Asian
countries you're not supposed to know
right the doctor won't tell you uh China
as well yeah well there's a reason why
there
but like in in Nigeria for instance the
doctor would be like oh yeah no uh
baby's healthy maybe uh buy a football
yeah okay but it's against the lord it's
a lesbian
oh yeah hit me how about this this has
driven me crazy my whole [__] life
and I forgot about it since we've been
doing the show and somebody did it
yesterday I had a big question somebody
got me something I go where'd you get
that or wait I lost something and I
found it I go where'd you find that
how'd you do it he goes Magic
I hate the magic just tell me what tell
me the answer the question magic you
know that guy like how'd you get that TV
in here magic no give me the answer do
you think maybe that's a guy who just
says magic all day good morning magic
yeah maybe maybe but don't you break
into my hotel room yeah
even Magic's not magic you know how'd
you tell the woman in half there's a
mechanics to it is that actual mad but
at least they have a reason for saying
magic that's true that's their job right
you're just a [__] jerk off jerk off
and he walked away I was like well I
still want to know but now I guess I
don't know
how about this guy I'll tell you but
then I'd have to kill you yeah yeah kill
me just kill me kill me right now yeah I
hate I hate life that I have to talk to
you yeah I don't like the offer you both
meals on the flight when she knows one
meal doesn't exist ah yes that's a great
one would you like the chicken or the
vegetables I'd like the chicken without
a chicken [__] you knew that right
and make 80 chicken and 20 veggie we're
all gonna want the chicken there's gonna
be a couple of stragglers but come on
it's like when they do decaf and coffee
oh my God that's a beef I was in a hotel
room once I get three decaf packets one
regular in what world does that ratio
make a [__] lick of sense exactly
I once uh sorry I got really angry yeah
I've never seen so animated I had a lot
of regular coffee that's why there's a
hotel called the West End in Bengaluru
uh in India which is kind of like this
old uh Colonial property where
they'll unpack your bag
oh like uh the guy kind of came in and
put my bag down and I went to take a
piss and I came back and he was
unrolling my socks what and I'm like
what the [__] are you doing he's like
I'm your Butler and I'm like hey I'm I'm
an Indian boarding school child so for
me to make a man older than me touch my
shoes is like hugely
so don't touch my socks and shoes also
like I have junk in that suitcase that
you don't need to see you know like I
have weed in there I have other stuff in
there what is wrong on your joint just
like good evening sir yeah no that's
crazy that's very intrusive dude this is
uh I'll tell you this this is a great
sort of Dubai story if you're ever going
to Dubai so in Dubai if you look like an
artist you get What's called the Dubai
check which is where you know if you
have piercings with your tattoos they
will undo the lining of your suitcase
unroll every sock it takes an hour at
costumes to see if you have drugs oh and
if you uh
if you're covered drugs in Dubai you're
not coming out for a while because they
have a zero tolerance policy bye-bye and
I know I know a musician who plays the
guitar and he's been playing it since he
was three years old and he had shoes in
his bag and underneath the shoes they
found a stubbed out joint ah just like
that much of a joint right and so he's
like I'm going away for [__] life and
like these guys are making calls because
they're like okay we got one yeah and he
picks up his guitar and he's like I'm
not gonna get to touch a guitar again
for the next 20 years and starts to play
in the terminal
and all these guys just kind of sit down
and watch him play for like 20 minutes
and they're like we're letting you go
because we've never seen anyone play
guitar at this level wow we're putting
you on a flight get the [__] out of the
UA and never come back wow Brittany
grinder should have dribbled a ball
that would never happen with comedy let
me do tight eights where are you from
what's up with Airline security hey are
you married sir they just start beating
the [__] out of you
take my guitar please I gotta I gotta
peeve all right hit me uh guy who got
engaged messages me who I'm not even
close with messages me first yeah the
engage already peeved just leave me
alone he goes uh I got engaged it's Mark
and uh no it's a guy who got engaged and
he wrote me uh you know we got engaged
and we're trying to pay it forward so we
want to set you up with someone Pay It
Forward how about you suck my dick oh
like a charity yeah like we want to help
out I don't you think I want to be set
up Yeah by your [__] candy ass yeah
when the setup happens because in India
that's like a marriage right yeah all
right but when like not the same case
here but do you only meet at the date
then I guess I don't know I said no yeah
good you got Raya you're good I'm good
Tinder you're fine well Israel famous
people who tenders it's hot people and
him and me yeah
and hairy boys
hairy boys
the Kevin Spacey novel
but the argument is they know what's
good for you better than you do Aha and
he's got engaged so he's like I know
about coming together yeah you don't
know and then because they know the real
you right like they know you like you
can't see yourself people try to set me
up a lot I try to get set up a lot yeah
tall full head of hair successful
or maybe they're like he doesn't have
long much
[Laughter]
I mean he's a hunk here's a hunk would
you oh yeah yeah you would well
I mean you'd be in the new special then
yeah that's true story about you that's
true so you don't like getting set up at
all I don't I don't like the eye it's so
much pressure
I agree I've somehow
I I've never dated dated really like
I've I've had one terrible first date
where I
was trying to date a girl before her and
I was trying to pick up a girl on the
Wednesday before I met this girl on a
Friday and this girl forgot that we were
on a date so I kind of showed up at her
house and she was in shorts and had like
a you know just a bun on and I was like
are we going out she's like can we do
this another time at the front door so
now this new girl on the way to her
house I called her 20 minutes before the
date and I'm like are we still on and
she's like yeah I'm in the shower I'll
see you in 20. then
I forgot to open the door for her so I
ran over to my side of the car remember
that I forgot to open the door for her
ran around the car
then realized that this looked weird so
ran around the car another time so I ran
around the car twice and then opened her
door which I guess she thought was for
good luck or some [__] you're like I'm
OCD I had for Long Island Iced Teas and
threw up on her oh
that's like the last day yeah the woman
when I see is like that's that's a bad
what are you thinking that's a bad drink
yeah but I feel like here at least in
New York this protocol right like
there's the coffee yeah and then there's
the the dinner that will not lead to sex
and then there's the dinner where you
don't eat which will lead to sex like
isn't that the I just go drink Sex yeah
same night yeah we're adults let's knock
it out knock it out the sex is actually
romantic you
Mark what is your one drink all right
pick it up pick it up
well you can tell more about someone
from the sex than the dinner I think
because the dinner is very phony oh is
that right yeah you have a masters ah
but the sex it's like put a lamp shade
up my ass or whatever you know but first
sex isn't real sex that's true that's
true 56th sex is real sex yeah when
she's just laying there that's the real
her yes exactly where you get the weird
sideways one
will you try to be porn stars you're
like let me put your leg this way and do
this and she's like what are you doing
it never works sorry yeah
weird ending of this episode because
we're all thinking about something we
tried
yeah we do it five minutes for bits if
you're kicking anything around here I
don't know about anything good here do
you have anything you're kicking around
uh premise they're Half Baked I have one
where I'm like it's not a great one but
I think
I was thinking about what America does
about gun control and I don't think your
guns are going to go away so and I don't
think you're gonna stop selling guns so
maybe for a one year period of time only
women buy guns oh and what does that do
to America interesting so I was like
okay murder would go down but assault
would go up
once a week your girlfriend would shoot
you in the leg
lecture you take you to the hospital
bring you home and [__] your brains out
uh yeah because make for some good sex
yeah yeah uh for the first time you'd
know the anniversary like
yeah with the gun down uh I think what
else was it there would be no more
unsolved like crimes right there would
be no true crime like uh the body was
found in the forest they'd be like no we
heard yelling in the forest for six
hours
until somebody screamed you're making me
do this
that's not you it's me and then that's
it that's what I'm kicking around right
now I like it yeah I like it ladies with
guns because he's with guns there's not
a lot of female murderers or serial
killers no they do they do murder but no
they do serial killers well women murder
like with a drop of antifreeze in your
oatmeal over like six months but I don't
think women want murder I think women
want stockholms in they want to be heard
you know right they've used a gun like a
tool just be like listen to me yeah and
be like for the first time I am can you
put on the silencer
yeah I think you got some here yeah yeah
there's some in there yeah I think yeah
just be a threat like uh you want to get
dinner tonight nah let's stay in and
she's like
and you're like okay we'll get Italian
yeah few of Wars but Wars would last
longer yeah yes they draw it out like
Russian Ukraine would never end this
Olga Petrova running at Ivanka or
whatever with two guns right right
please fight no uh yeah picking a movie
would suck for the guy yeah what should
we see uh 13 Going on 30 are good Fellas
he's like we'll see
like I said not very good I don't know
what I like man I don't know if I have
anything worthwhile quite a lot there
um
do you have anything I got one of you uh
yeah this is also just yeah nothing here
maybe but so I went on the Safari and
you got these guides this like
Australian guy he's got fatigues on he's
driving the jeep he's super manly and
there's this animal rights lady in the
Jeep with us and she's very Progressive
but yet animal life is very conservative
it's strict gender roles it's
territorial it's segregated you know
that there was one point where like a
male wildebeest was [__] or humping
another male world and the guy was like
oh what's going on there and he's like
ah there's two males they're not having
sex they're just playing so it's very
strict you know old school it's like the
50s you know and uh I just thought it
could be funny like what if a lion
didn't want to do the gender roles you
know it's like the lions got to get the
food the male line and the female
watches the Cubs and what if the male
lines like [__] this I want to do a
podcast or you know the girl's like I
want to be a graphic designer I don't
want to do this either
because we have the privilege to sway
and run around and do different [__]
would also be funny in that world like
you need the dude to kill
yes yeah that's funny to me like you
need like they don't get to choose right
with other animals and there's no victim
[__] like they'll just kill an Impala
and that's it that's not like a protest
like we got to stop these lines from
killing a pot we're people too you know
it's just they don't get to talk about
the killing afterwards like if I had to
kill for my wife I wouldn't shut the
[__] up
I would bring home the body we would
talk about the body you would there
would be a selfie with the body yes you
would bang me for the body you know they
put me lines or just little ears of body
so yeah no gloating no gloating that's
good overkilling all right I think we
got something here it's very old school
I have a this is just an idea ahead and
there's like nothing really here yet but
I I threw this out there and this kind
of got something but it needs more but
it was about how uh
I met with someone at Tick Tock and I
was like what's the deal all my videos
get pulled down on Tick Tock
everything's like hate speech to you
guys I said I had a Nazi joke it pulled
down she goes well you can't there's
robots that can't detect sarcasm so they
if you talk about Nazis they have no
sense of humor about it I was like well
it sounds like a Nazi yeah
you know what I mean so that hip I was
like I don't know the [__] to go with it
but it's like is that good for anything
robots or monitoring
that's who's in charge of comedy on your
app is robots yeah this is an art form
this is all subjective and we got a
robot at the helm that's crazy I don't
wanna I feel
I feel nervous calling this an art form
because because then the angle is like
you know what if uh [__] if you sell
like a pollock and a robot's like nope
right right but then but you know what I
mean like maybe that is the angle I
don't know maybe there's uh you go to
like there should be uh like when you go
to a comedy show at the seller or
whatever there should be a capture for a
comedy show
where you like big like you know
whatever squares have buses in there yes
and if you fail you're allowed into the
combination oh if you [__] that up
yeah robots yeah
10 minutes on you know airline food and
it'll do it I know like all these kids
are using it for term papers and [__]
it's blowing up it's amazing remember
like doing papers on I mean we were like
the end of the beginning of the internet
so it was like you find something you're
like you [__] plagiarize this right
right but now it's like you really
[__] can get caught I know in the
back of Rolling Stone there was an ad
for a buyer turn paper someone would do
it for you I remember that yeah yeah
dude in my college we had something
called the honor System where you could
take uh you could take an exam take a
paper anywhere on campus as long as it
was Outdoors right so you could take
your exam go out into the Lawns and kind
of ride it and they had 16 students who
were like the honor police who knew
nobody knew who they were right and they
would rat you out whoa like I cheated in
80 of my exams yeah
Nobody's Gonna Catch You So I just like
going to my dorm room and like finish
off my people yeah no I did College
online because I've quit college to go
do comedy my parents have got to finish
it so I finished it in New York online
and you just got the you got Google
right there you're you're it's so stupid
but I got the degree
well uh man sorry we didn't do your bit
oh no I mean the bid is whatever it's
I'll figure it out but maybe a Nazi
would like the Jew jokes
you know you go back to the Nazi thing
oh yeah send them more Jew jokes yeah
that's how you get back into technology
jokes right send that robot two jokes
because it's a Nazi yeah well that might
be no no no no it's not connected here
no no no I'm thinking I'm thinking no I
think the angle that is funny if you're
like the Jew jokes are those are words
don't get pulled down exactly man these
this really is Nazis yeah that could be
the angle
okay man they find these two jokes
hilarious yeah there's something there
stolen from you all right all right so
here's some dates oh we got some dates
from here well go straight to March
because those February dates are pushed
sorry uh but yeah that's where I'm at
all right
um
Baltimore Sacramento of course watches
new special landing on Netflix yeah
maybe my eyes are bad and that's far
away so I wouldn't be able to do
Milwaukee Austin Providence New Haven oh
Brea Improv that's fun that's a fun one
yeah San Antonio get the breakfast tacos
good time Houston uh Pittsburgh yeah
nice so you got some good rooms yep with
my three new minutes they built it
though wait that singer songwriter is
gonna bury you
awesome man do you want sound dates yeah
yeah
going on also gippodega cat whiskey and
Bodega catwhiskey.com get [__] it [__]
it I got uh Vancouver coming up uh
Seattle Portland keep going down
Salamanca uh what else Salt Lake City
Huntington yeah Atlantic City in
February there you go uh Royal Oak March
2nd that's a good Room Minneapolis March
3rd that's a big one yeah another
Milwaukee New Haven Connecticut Boston
Boston Boston whoa what's that the
Wilbur one of the best country that many
nights five nights four right now we're
gonna add a feather oh yeah yeah and
then uh Miami Orlando Ponte Verde which
is basically Jacksonville Atlanta
Charleston Durham Charlottesville
tickets still available for that one
yeah Norfolk DC added the second one
there Wilkes bar and Port Chester more
coming soon but we we love you guys
thanks for buying tickets yes and get uh
you got a ton of great stuff on YouTube
too so check out all of us on YouTube we
got a ton of stuff I'm all over the road
Hawaii uh whoa boy Miami I can't read
any of this um
oh I'm doing uh we're doing the Super
Bowl with Chrysler that'll be fun in
Phoenix yeah we're not doing the Super
Bowl we're going to the Super Bowl we're
doing a theater the night before five or
two and a half times
holy [__] she's opening for me I thought
you would have mentioned that no no you
know I hit her once
um let's see Skyline in February and
then after that Rochester comedy to
Carlson laugh it up all kinds of fun
stuff Poughkeepsie New York come on by
we got a special tape again March so I'm
really trying to go down in Chicago nice
got the Vic all right you were weird
about saying it last week uh I never
know what we can say but you could say
whatever yeah you're right [__] it the
n-word all right thanks guys
that's an end word thank you boys all
right thanks guys thanks beer
[Music]
and I get down in the same way
s dangerous
out to lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
we might
be true
[Music]